in Tennessee we've opened up and there's
a sense that it's calming down a little
bit that all the stress in the air is
starting to with a lot of people
dissipate a lot of people are still
completely in freakout mode the hysteria
continues but what happens is is that
little things between people become big
things with this added stress it grows
right mm-hmm and the weird thing that
I'm hearing from nationally and from my
neighbors is the people are the weapon
in this deal right it's who's where is
this gonna come from and is there gonna
be a spike and is that guy gotta make me
sick and that lady in the store just
coughed and so it's this weird it's kind
of like being on the moon it's just all
the stores are back open and we're all
back in the stores but everyone's kind
of looking around and so you got a
default to be an extra kind and going
out of your way to waving especially
people got masks on you can't see if
someone's smile and it's just just it's
just different its unique yeah yeah
everybody looks like a bank robber
that's it I think that's the way some of
our brains are responding yeah we've
been trained our whole life with the eye
mask it all means something and so now
it means something different yeah we get
to put on our I get to put on a grown-up
pairs of pants these days and decide I'm
gonna be kind to this person because my
brain is telling me look out my brain is
telling me - my heart rate to get up a
little bit yeah absolutely and that
makes it hard to make those decisions
have you been out and about
oh of course I've been to work every day
I mean we're in skeleton crew here
before we brought the team back Monday
but and I've been out to restaurants and
everything else I you know I really
haven't changed a whole lot except I'm
not allowed to travel and I'm not
allowed to come to some places or an
open that I would normally go to but um
and you know that some things are
adapted but I'm not you know even down
to you know I do it two and a half mile
hike almost every morning over in a park
in our area and there's people coming up
the path towards you and some of them
are just like hey you know whatever and
others go off headed off into the woods
I head off into the woods and stand
there and look at you as you go by you
know as though you're a deer walking
yeah and I'm like you know or a tiger
worse deer wouldn't you wouldn't
yeah so but I mean I always just show
you to them too you know but it's just I
and I try to you know if they're trapped
I try to give them room because I know
they're concerned about its be kind of
somebody else that's where they are
where I am as I'm going for a walk so
how do you how do you balance
hospitality versus what I would say
reality and because I'm wrestling with
that to do I look at the data and the
science and what the scientists are
saying which is one thing which set do I
write which coin they're flipping or do
I just wear a mask and move out of the
way because it's gonna make this person
who's walking towards me you're right
where they are I mean like you know I
had some folks at the house other night
and you know one lady you know was elbow
bumping and another lady's like full-on
hugs you know so okay whatever I mean
I'm meet you where you are I like what
I'm doing and you know I'm gonna respect
where you are if you're you know and
just give you give you permission to be
where you are and you get a give me
permission to be where I am if we're
about tolerance I'll do that we're gonna
be alright yeah if we will all open up
this country with that attitude yeah I
mean if you if you don't want to come to
a place I understand yeah and if I do
you need to understand fair enough
you know that's that's if you come at me
elbow first I'm gonna elbow you yeah and
if you come at me hugging I don't wanna
hug you
yeah I'm just gonna go no I'm not doing
that and that's cool that's all the list
she wasn't mean or angry she said I'm
not doing that I got grandbabies and I'm
trying to stay you know where I can see
them and all that cool honor to
understand what a gift I love that I
love that I love that balance of
hospitality and then moving forward it's
just good you know it's actually just
respecting other people so it is just
you know what didn't what a novel idea
was I don't need it I don't need to look
across the street and see what my
neighbor's doing and bother him he can
do what he wants he's over there I don't
need to call the police on him I don't
need to not call the police on him I
don't need to even worry about him it's
his deal I can just I got a full-time
job taking care of this one little bald
guy it's a big job so one of the things
you you say a lot around here is we're
just we're giving grandma's wisdom to
the masses and how many times did my
grandma I'll say John you take care of
you
when I'd go tattle when I was four right
or when I was nine John you go take care
of you I got some grandbabies I got one
that's a tattletale right now she's in
that tattletales and she said yeah I
think you don't coming here tell me that
why not Papa David it's Ross you're
you're not the judge you're not the jury
you're not in charge of justice and
you're not gonna get me to be in charge
of justice just deal with it all right
so they make a playroom and hit them no
but yeah but the crazy wisdom of be
respectful be hospitable and you take
care of you and it's okay and I don't
have to I don't have to make fun of you
or be mad at you for where you are no
it's tempting that's my baggage to
curating but I don't have to do that so
but you know so I you know we we we the
state of Tennessee is opened and her
office opened on Monday we opened
voluntarily the week before for our team
our team was asked to come back unless
they've got special circumstances now
and you know I'm large we've had a
wonderful week around here in terms of
the way people have treated each other
and they're happy to be out of their
nuclear caves and back at work and
nuclear winter is out here you know but
um it's weird not anything but it took
it took a day or two for folks to even
just get used to being around other
people again you know it was kind of
it's kind of a weird vibe for the first
hour or two back in the building so to
speak and and but you know I tweet that
and then I get hate stuff all over
social media my employees and some of
you people are just idiots I mean really
it's just good lord your parent did your
parents raise one smart one but wouldn't
you but I mean golly you know so but
obviously if somebody's ill here they
don't need to be here or if they are
their immune deficient they don't need
to be here we're fine with that that's a
special circumstances right now they got
a lot of child care I got more people
out for child care problems well in just
the fact that y'all the US this company
is having that conversation if you're
stuck in a childcare situation holler or
any of ironies while I'm trying to kill
my employees we win best place to work
in the nation well inks magazine
incredible company our size in Inc
magazines ratings and so you know I
guess I guess some of you
wrong you know that's it's Pleasant
until you kill us day yeah it was a
great place to work before I died yeah
oh but it's just you know I understand
and there's some real you know real
things you learn about the human spirit
through this process